Speaker 1: Donald Trump in a dangerous,
confused all capital letters rant once
again. And the question continues to be,
is this guy actually running for president
or is he just posting to truth, social.
Speaker 2: Censure.
Speaker 1: And hoping that people show up and beg
him to save the country, even though Republicans
don't seem particularly interested? Take a look
at this. Delusional, angry, furious. All capital
letters rant that he posted to truth social, at
least for now, resisting getting back on Twitter
quote. And remember, it's all caps, folks. It's
caps all the way down. Quote, How can the January
6th UN Select Committee make criminal referrals
when they haven't spoken about or studied those
that rigged the 2020 election, the troops not
being brought in by Pelosi or now the election
fraud determinative lever revealed by Twitter.
These are the real criminals. I think there is
four lies there. First of all, the committee can
make criminal referrals because House committees
can make criminal referrals. That's number one.
Number two, the 2020 election was not rigged.
Number three, the troops were not not brought
in by Pelosi. There is no evidence Nancy Pelosi
blocked, nor even had the power to control the
troops. And there is no evidence that Donald Trump
requested tens of thousands of troops as he has
claimed to. And number three, the Twitter files
did not determinative reveal any election fraud.
They revealed that both the Trump administration
and the Biden campaign had the email addresses of
people they could email to request content be
removed. And if the content violated Twitter's
terms of service, Twitter sometimes removed it.
Trump continuing in all capital letters, quote,
This was election interference. The disinformation
was coming from the FBI and Facebook. It was
coming from Adam Schiff and Democrat operatives.
This was a very damaging story to Biden before the
election and they were going to kill it. Bottom
line, the election was rigged and stolen. Miranda
Devine, as interviewed by Mark Levin. Amazing.
So what's the endgame here? Is Trump's final
foray into public life going to be announcing that
he's running in 2024, staying home as he has for
the last month, and posting all capital letters
messages to troth essential to argue about how
unfairly he was treated. Telling lie after lie
after lie until he eventually, either for health
reasons or for some other undetermined reason,
says I'm actually not going to run. I have other
things I want to do because this is not shaping
up to be a very successful political run, that's
for damn sure. And at some point, if he believed
Joe Biden had to leave his house in order to win,
which, by the way, apparently he didn't. At some
point, Trump's going to have to do something other
than just posting all capital letters, messages on
troth essential. Now I get it. It's early worth,
23 months away from the 2024 election. But is this
going to be it? Is this going to be the last gasp
and whimper of Trump's failed political career?
I don't know. We will wait and see together